ivan chagnaud propose en compagnie de
gilbert le voyage sans passeport
la semaine dernière nous avions laissé
chez nous vers le camp guyane dans un
village dogba hier et aujourd'hui
où allez-vous une grande nuit toujours
avec votre manière nous sommes obligés
voyage à 400 km de saint laurent du
maroni bretagne et nouveaux arrivants en
vue du village des indiens chez lequel
notre bannière va chercher des guides
pour les chasser ce papier en bleu donc
parlons de l'année dernière
aussitôt arrivés le bruit du moteur
attire les lanières qui sont très
curieuses nature c'est les enfants pour
l'instant oui oui les enfants se
trouvent la plupart du temps au bord de
l'eau il aime beaucoup l'eau dans les
comprend et de recherche la chaleur sont
recouverts de colliers de perles ce sens
des indiens roucou yens on les appelle
roucou yens parce qu'il se teignent le
corps en rouge avec une sorte de vue
d'une teinture qui est extraite d'une
graine qu'on appelle roucou d'où leur
nom aux couilles n ils sont vraiment
rouge tous les écrevisses leur peau
naturellement qu'ils recevront à bronzer
un peu rouge sauver un beau soleil que
l'on a pris un peu trop rapidement
non pas du tout la même teinte que les
afriques
il est unijambiste des liens ils se
débrouillent d'ailleurs pas mal mieux
que moi par moment comme pour descendre
des canaux et plus de facilité il se
servait de ses deux béquilles comme de
perches
ce sont ses amis c'est l'indien non mais
en principe quand il ya un autre qui
arrive on se donne une poignée de main
bien entendu ce sont tous tous les lieux
à peu près quatre hommes que l'on
appelle qu'athènes avant tous les autres
ténors étonnant qu'il se donnait alors
ils se réunissent autour de lot pour
savoir ce qu'il vient faire ici
alors le bagnard explique par geste
puisqu'il parle lundi et l'esprit que ce
qui donne ce qu'il attend d'eux
clairement je deviens chasser les
papillons
voilà où une femme passe à 13 ans y
annonce que les papillons ça ne les
intéresse pas personnellement le médium
se mange oui c'est ça mais accepte que
ça puisse intéresser les autres dont ils
prennent le banian pour un enfant
l'homme bord nous on ne fait pas plus de
mal que ça alors voyez le chef principal
désigne les guides qui l'a choisi pour
le bailleur sitôt choisi par en chasse
il ne faut pas perdre votre temps
le bagnard miley s'est évadé il rentrera
au bagne après où il risquera ce premier
jour de prise en août les programmes et
troyes relégués à vis en guyane ils sont
assez nonchalant
ils emmènent avec eux leur arc leurs
flèches toujours dans l'espoir d'un
gibier qui pourrait rencontrer un gibier
toujours a convenu que notre foi
je suis resté un moment fort et je n'ai
pas vu prospecte donc ils comptent peu
là dessus pour se nourrir
coli frimas qu'il le mange que du couac
qui squattent fait une ceux du manioc
qui râpé et c'est chez audi tout cas
revivre alors pas du tout alors il pêche
beaucoup de poissons qu'ils agrémentent
avec leur coin oui aujourd'hui croissant
et du coi fait quand il n'ya pas de quoi
son bar mange que du couac en 35 dans
l'eau ça gonfle à roissy sont tous oui
trois cas de figure de quoi qui nous
avait le l'estomac qui prend trois fois
son bolide
le très nourrissant oui il n'y a pas de
vieille agents n'ai pas vu une belle
race peu entendu on ne voit que les
hommes qui résiste aux sélection
naturelle alors obligatoire mobile sont
très paternel j'ai vu beaucoup de
beaucoup de gestes comme ça avec un ami
ils partent en chasse et environ 2
heures du matin il ya déjà chaud il fait
très chaud et vers 9 heures on est déjà
vers les 40 42 degrés et il tient son
filet glorieusement en l'air we are il a
deux fils et l'un fille léa manche un
filet sans manche le filet sans manche
va servir tout à l'heure pour la chasse
fameux papillon
luffy la manche c'est des fois qu'il ya
un papillon qui s'amusent à traverser le
fleuve il ya beaucoup d'ailleurs qui
vont une rive hollandais salariés
français toujours du côté hollandais aux
français et jamet vice versa à ce
constat se demander je ne sais pas si
c'est la position où ils ont vraiment
c'est curieux peinture manque quelque
chose qui peut être nous et chaque
métier existe dans la première chose
qu'ils sont obligés de rechercher un
endroit pour accoster dans cette forêt
avec cette délégation luxuriante
c'est très difficile ont marqué malgré
tour on circule encore aisément il ya
beaucoup de llano couderc de coupante
mais comme la forêt très touffu la
végétation d'aucune mal en dessous
survivants ce sont nous la pourriture
des feuilles pour il des trompes tous
les métiers hors des fois des arts pied
qui vous tendent presque en passant
fusil
alors la meilleure solution c'est de
trouver l'embouchure d'une petite crique
airs d'une rivière parce que toutes les
rivières s'appelle creek là-bas de
pouvoir rentrer le canot de la marée et
de faire le reste à pied parce qu'ils
sentent obligés pour chasser ce papillon
de trouver un endroit très dégagée par
ce que le morpho mines et loos le
papillon bleu voilà c'est parce que
dénonce un petit papillon vulgaire comme
la bannière l'appel que naquit à peu
d'intérêt qu'il n'a pas de prix à la
revente
alors ce papillon bleu vie dans la forêt
dans les grands arbres
il est pratiquement impossible de courir
après dans les arts on s'accrochera au
liane et tout seul ce ne serait pas
possible ils sont obligés pour cela de
faire des tracés faut commencer par être
bûcheron avant de trancher sur wii pour
traverser les rivières des fruits est
impossible et tellement d'hésitation qui
la recouvre ses pôles on met les pieds
ils ont beaucoup plus vite fait
d'abattre un arbre qui tombe au travers
de passer par dessus surtout cet art
c'est une espèce de peines doit traiter
environ trois minutes pour le pape lui
même pas plus leur veulent exactement
j'ai minutes et trois minutes oui
pourtant leurs instruments ne s'est pas
tellement alors une fois dans le dans
l'endroit choisi par le chasseur le
grand chasseur spécialistes
le chasseur est seul en piste vers les
vins des indiens se dispersent
il a choisi un endroit qui forment
couloir au long d'une crique comme le
papillon va sentir une certaine liberté
une certaine aisance pour son vol il va
s'engager irrémédiablement dans le
couloir et il va passer se présenter
devant les chasseurs qui à l'aide d'une
amorce fait d'un vieux papillons ou des
fois d'un papier gauloise bleue la tire
à lui est d'un coût de fines et très
adroit le capture
bien que les ans il est assis sur le
tronc d'arbre griffes et sa facilité
j'ai essayé une seule fois eu beaucoup
du mal vous avez réussite oui j'étais
plus fort que lui pour les papillons
divers et pour le blush n'est pas très
fort et l'oeuvre une technique
particulière d'ailleurs à la guyane et
ce papillon qui a environ 12 cm
d'envergure est magnifique et d'un bleu
très intense on l'appelle on dit qu'il
est d'un bleu électrique aux joueurs ça
ressemble un très joli satin sitôt pris
le papillon et d'appuyer l'endroit du
thorax pour qu'ils ce qu'il meure et
s'étouffe et on lui enlève l'abdomen qui
devient graisseux et abîmerait les ailes
une autre espèce que l'on appellerait
ténor qu'est la même couleur que le le
bleu mais qui ne descend jamais un plus
de 3 4 mètres du sol pour l'attraper
bagnard est obligé de se hisser à sa
hauteur et de le chasser de la même
façon que l'autre le méné l'os c'est
très pénible de rester les heures en
plein soleil
magnifique il a acheté ce chapeau à
saint laurent et l'a payé je crois 2500
francs il a trouvé qu'elle ait fait une
affaire je crois que c'est un européen
qui a ramené sa de france s'est piqué a
vendu sa comme ceux d'hier et entraînera
l'arrivée très bonne qualité ils étaient
très contents de voir ce chapeau il va
devenir un peu chambré certainement très
utile lors des x dans la matinée il
arrive à attraper jusqu'à 30 papillon
parfois les enfants que deux ailes
papillons les allemands complu à langer
il est de la même couleur que l'autre
une fois pris le papillon est mis dans
une papillote fait de papier cristal
pour ne pas qu'il s'abîme au contact des
autres dans la boîte et une fois étalé
le papillon romain magnifique buffet
julie des fois même jusqu'à 14 cm
réalise heures de sortie
ce papillon qui est un insecte mimétique
ressemble étrangement à une chouette et
on retrouve l'iris la pupille et les
couleurs de papillons en fête les cas y
disposer comme les tuiles sur a3 il ya
toute la collection des ce que l'on
appelle et l'icône esquissant très jolie
des couleurs rouge et jaune sur fond
noir qui s'attrape
un peu dans la forêt sur les lisières
surtout dans les endroits on peut
dégager
c'est celui là que je chassais moi
particulièrement parce qu'il fallait
courir après comment être bagnard était
pas capable
l'express la jambe unique bien sûr même
souvent importe ces paquets six mois
qu'ils les débits ceci ça c'est papillon
qui s'appelle papilio fait partie de la
famille des papes il y aura dix ans ce
petit papillon hills où les arômes et ce
qui cause elle les bannières appelle ça
des pagailles à fait particulière il va
essayer d'ailleurs on en attrape et ce
papillon ça trappe avec le filet à
manches il vit sous les la feuille des
arums qui d'une plante que l'on trouve
les fleurs chez les fleuristes en france
on ne voit jamais la feuille puisqu'elle
est très grande
oui sur la gauche
laplante vie dans l'eau la feuille des
passes à peu près de 3 4 mètres sous la
surface
c'est très difficile pour notre nid
jambi de se tenir en équilibre sur un
cannois font presque plat la plupart du
temps envoyé un bon départ le le manche
qui est très long et rallo ça y est tout
se termine toujours par une partie de
plaisir ou et les années en profite on
est tellement bonne fée 24° à peu près
même la nuit
la bourgogne à l'autre oui je vois tous
très déterminé c'est beaucoup plus dur
ailleurs de remonter en canot avec une
famille rom que dans des cendriers
eh bien merci je vais dès la semaine
prochaine nous irons à la pêche au coin
gauche de très gros points sens que le
lundi à ne pèche callac et bien merci
ils rejoignent au vous a proposé un
voyage sans passeport cette émission a
été réalisée avec le concours de gibert
luck et de solange péters montage pierre
michel rey sont paul bonnefond
illustration sonore denise glaser